[Music]
I suppose this touches on the psychology
of leadership - which is a mess by the
way
well let's what's the fundamental
characteristic of a leader well here's
one a leader knows a leader is someone
who knows where he or she is going will
that be the first thing is like how are
you gonna lead unless you have a
destination
okay well the destination implies an
ethic and then you need to be able to
communicate that and you communicate
you're your destination with a story now
if I want to motivate people and that's
not the right way to think about you
know because you shouldn't want to
motivate people
that's management idiots speak that is
what you should do is figure out
something that's worth doing right that
you really think is worth doing
something that you would actually commit
a substantial proportion of your life to
and you should have deep reasons for
pursuing it and then if you're a leader
well first of all you have that
established but the second is that you
can communicate that okay and then you
communicate that in the manner that also
appeals to others other people's sense
of purpose and so you'd say to someone
like if I wanted to move forward with
you on an enterprise I would have to say
well here's the purpose of the
enterprise and here's the reasons that
it's not only eminently justifiable but
more justifiable than anything else we
could be doing at the same time and then
I'd have to say well here's what's in it
for me and here's what's in it for you
and here's why the two of us together
can further the enterprise and further
what's in it for you and further for
what what's in it for me and then you
you have a situation there that Piaget
Jean Piaget the developmental
psychologist called an equilibrated
state so an equilibration state is a
situation that's set up by two or more
people where everyone is participating
in the state voluntarily so and he got
that he derived that notion in part by
looking at how children set up games so
if children are going to set up a
pretend game
what they do is they negotiate a little
narrative to begin with it's almost like
they generate a little play and they
assign everyone their parts and then
they manifest the play and that's how
they think but everyone has to accept
their part voluntarily right or the game
won't continue now PS J's ethical claim
ethical analytic claim was that a game
everyone plays voluntarily is more
sustainable and productive than one the
people have to be forced to play and
that was his fundamental distinction
between the utility of freedom versus
the utility of tyranny because you could
say well the authoritarians win do this
or else that's a way of organizing a
society but Piaget is claimed was the
enforcement costs are so high that the
free society will out-compete the
authoritarian society across time now if
you're going to set up an organization
you can set it up on authoritarian lines
but then you're you're basically
compelling people to perform with
punishment and fear it's better to
motivate them positively and the way you
do that is say look here's the goal
here's your role here's what this will
add to your life practically and in
terms of say significant engagement and
involvement and then if you can do that
people will you know with with certain
other preconditions in place competence
for example in a certain amount of
conscientiousness then people will
participate in the game voluntarily you
don't have to overlord them and so
that's that's well and if you have any
experience in the world at all in
complex processes you know that that's
the optimal circumstances under which to
engage with other people it's like hey
we're all in the same boat we're going
somewhere interesting everyone's got a
role to play we're all in this together
and it's working out for each of us as
well now there's a there's a corollary
to that which is an interesting one so
imagine this so let's say you have your
organization and you have your goals and
you and your you're out to do something
worthwhile and you can tell a good story
about that so you've got people on board
now you really want to get people on
board and so now you've got two choices
you could you could tell people
go home and spend four or five hours and
formulate a plan about how you're going
to contribute to this organization okay
or you could say no no you go home and
you formulate a plan for your life that
includes your job at this organization
as a subset all right and then you run
imagine you do that with a hundred
people in each group then you run those
people in a head-to-head competition for
a year to see who's more most productive
the answer the people who formulated a
plan for their life they're ten percent
more productive so you can gain a 10
percent increment in corporate level
productivity by having your people write
out a plan for their life we have a
program like that called future
authoring online that thousands of
people have done now that increased the
probability that university students
would stay in university by 30 percent
so and that's part of the narrative
issue it's like what you want from from
your employees is what you want them to
be doing something useful with their
life that they're engaged in because
like if they can't do that for their
life what the hell makes you think
they're gonna do that for your
organization and then you want them to
see how working for you serves their
higher-order purpose and if it doesn't
because maybe they can't formulate that
that hierarchical really integrated
hierarchical relationship well then they
should find another job
right because that isn't the job for
them if it's running if your job is
running at cross-purposes with your life
how the hell are you going to be
motivated you're not at least you're
gonna be stymied constantly by the by
the internal contradiction so and
imagine what you're trying to do is
you're trying to get everyone pointing
in the same direction and I don't mean
by eliminating all diversity of opinion
or anything like that it's like the
overall organization has a point and
then everyone within that organization
has their point but they're integrated
within that overarching coherent of
coherent narrative that's the purpose of
leadership and to make that to make that
work at every level of the organization
that's what you want to do
it's very difficult but you you built a
cellar organization if you do that